on loan from football morning in America
every Monday exclusively on NBC
sports.com
Pete what do you make of these quotes
anonymous quotes about Tom Brady and the
Patriots well first of all I think Paul
Brown would like to have a word about
the subhead aside and I understand
publishers wanting to sell a book but
you know Parcells used to have a saying
let's not put a gold jacket on him yet
well you know Bellatrix gonna have a
gold jacket but let's let's calm down a
little bit and again I think he is
clearly in the discussion for the
greatest coach of all time but I don't
know anyway what do I think about those
things I think after year 1 after Super
Bowl 1 if somebody had said this is not
we could win with a lot of quarterbacks
maybe after Super Bowl 2 if you said
that maybe but after Super Bowl 3 and
after Super Bowl 4 and after the 16 and
OH season whoever says that's an idiot
period I mean it's just a stupid thing
to say
do you watch the games do you watch Tom
Brady play football I just when I read
that I just said that's I don't know who
said it I have no idea but I just think
it's foolish well the fact that Mike
Reiss says it's an assistant or maybe
former assistant who said that at least
adds a little credibility to somebody in
the building who knows what's going on
and watches these games no but but
here's but here's the point I doubt that
Bill Belichick ever would say even after
he had had you know eight Cabernets one
night I doubt he would ever say that
he's not anybody who would do that he's
not a Jimmie Johnson Jerry Jones guy he
just he's not he's not made to say
things like that if an assistant said
that I'm not I in no way am I doubting
Ian's reporting on this I think is
reporting is impeccable I've read parts
of this look I think it's really really
a great addition to the to the Belichick
lore and all the Belichick knowledge
but I just think whoever said that is is
dreaming most important game this
weekend is between whom I would say
Giants at Texans because one of those
teams is probably going to have their
season end this weekend it's probably
going to be the Giants and it's going to
be the thing about the Giants right now
when you look at them Dan I mean a few
people were saying it I said it at the
time and I'm not I'm not bringing this
up to say to puff out my chest or
anything like that but when you have a
chance to when you have a quarterback
who's 37 and you have a chance to take a
quarterback who's got a good chance to
be your long-term guy now I think Dave
gentlemen didn't take a quarterback in
cart because he loves sake on and
because he didn't love any of the
quarterbacks thoroughly in this class
which is understandable I think a lot of
people had a similar opinion it's not
exactly the same but it sure looks like
Eli is is you know especially with a bad
offensive line it's going to be hard for
him to make anything of this year not
used inside I think in these are two
teams with bad offensive lines and it's
crippling them both and I I just I think
this is going to be a grind it out 19 to
16 win for somebody that's going to be
an ugly win but the loser is gonna be
owing three and it's gonna be really
hard for him to come back what do you
expect tonight with the Browns and the
Jets I don't know I think it's a really
really compelling game I think it's a
lot of fun because both teams think that
they're pretty good and I think the one
thing about the Browns right now then
they've got so many interesting weapons
on defense that if Tyrod Taylor can just
make a few plays every game they ought
to win four games and I could see them
winning this game I could see them going
out to Oakland and winning I mean I
they're they're a real force on defense
that's the Saints so all they have
do is to be remotely competent on
offense to get a kicker who doesn't miss
every kick and they've got a chance to
win a few games talking to Peter King
NBC Sports joining us any concerns about
the Steelers aside from Le'Veon Bell no
I think I think a lot of these things
are happening because their defense is
playing so poorly and I mean think about
this Dan I mean this is what I sort of
think about when I think of teams that
look like they're going over to cliff
you know and there's all sorts of
discord and the one thing I keep
thinking about is I want you to look at
their average points per game allowed
does Ryan shazier went out after the
game last year in Cincinnati yeah they
played one really good defensive game
out of those whatever I think seven now
and the rest of them have been either
like in the 30s or the 40s and they're
they're just really struggling to be
competent on defense and as long as that
happened it's pretty hard even when
you're Big Ben to go into almost every
game knowing that if I don't score in
the 30s we're not winning this game and
I think that's where the Steelers are
right now what do you think the Packers
game plan is moving for with Aaron
Rodgers I think they should be
absolutely totally thrilled that the NFL
is made a mockery of the roughing the
passer rule because they have to feel
like we've got a we've got a 12th player
you know on offense now and it's the
referee standing behind Aaron Rodgers
anybody who hit some heart is gonna he's
going to get a flag now I'm not one of
those who think that this is over as far
as the what I consider to be the real
bastardization of this rule I think
sometimes NFL officials the NFL is all
the officiating Department want
everybody to think that they're going to
call plays a certain way and so to get
everybody to make sure that they are
careful on the field about certain
things that used to be defenseless
receiver
then this summer it was helmet-to-helmet
and right now it's roughing the past and
I don't think you're going to see that
Clay Matthews call being called very
much more but I do think that pass
rushers now know that a ridiculous
ridiculous calls are going to be made so
I've got to be careful and that's what
the NFL wants right now why does Jon
Gruden continue to bring up the topic or
mention the topic or when addressing the
topic says it's hard to find a good pass
rusher and then everybody has their own
you know punch line to this you traded
away one of the great pass rushers
he's like Donald Trump with the wall or
Donald Trump with the rust investigation
he can't leave it alone and he's not
convincing anybody no he's not
convincing and who who who possibly can
be convinced that that that Khalil Mak
didn't want to be on the Raiders that
was his first one you know and now how
hard it is to find a pass rusher it's
just it's almost insulting to the people
who listen really I I I hear him say
these things and I like I like John but
everything is a justification for
trading away a franchise pass rusher in
his prime the guy who over the last two
years in the NFL has impacted the
passing game via Pro Football Focus
their stats more than any other rusher
in the NFL you trade him in his prime
for two ones I wouldn't have traded them
for four ones well you also have Mack
playing well in these first two games so
you juxtapose that to the way it really
wouldn't matter it wouldn't matter to me
Danny I mean we've seen him play well
enough I I'm not trying to be
argumentative I'm just saying that even
if he had been pedestrian the first two
weeks I still would have said it's a
dumb trade I'll say it's a dumb trade
for the next three years I just I think
it's a dumb trade like I never
understood it I still can't to this day
yeah unless the Raiders realize that
they're not ready to compete in that I
felt like the John looked at this is I
have a two two-year grace period before
we get to Vegas and then once we get to
Vegas
then you're gonna see the team that I
want to put out on the field and you
know okay maybe but well let's say that
that's the case okay that's the case all
right
if Kaleo mac at twenty nine going to be
in a free fall in his career
i mean unless he unless he suffers two
horrible injuries between now and then
probably not he's still going to be a
huge impact player and you traded him
away with an awful history of drafting
in the first round and i it's just
mind-boggling is i never understand it
and as i as i wrote when this happened
if you extrapolate out the salary cap
numbers over the next seven years hmm
his average cap number will be if you do
it based on what the recent history has
been with the rise in the cap figures
that basically you're talking about
paying him on average ten or eleven
percent of your cap every year in my
opinion that's not exorbitant but
evidently they thought it would be Pete
good to talk to you enjoy the game
tonight and the weekends action as well
thanks a lot damn great hearing from you
that's Peter King NBC sports.com NFL
columnist for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]